and speaking about some of those
exciting uh draws guys of course one of
them was the one between Richie and Duda
in the first game of today's uh rounds
Richie first of all what a game that was
but I have to ask you one thing before
we start the analysis when you came into
the playing Hall you looked at the board
and you kind of started shaking your
head perhaps we will check it out right
now on the screen your
that moment right there yeah what was
that did you expect to play other player
or did you expect to play with a
different color what yeah sort of and
the other player pounds yeah
but I mean I didn't um
as you could see the game it didn't
matter too much but
yeah it was a bit of a surprise what
were your thoughts going at that point
yeah you put your head in your hands
yeah I was like okay let me recall what
he played I mean I played him recently
with white so okay it's not
um
total surprise yeah I mean in classical
so I I kind of remembered his repertoire
I was just trying to
trying to to adjust
yeah my prep and you you did play the
Vienna which was you know quite a
surprise for us uh we saw you playing it
in class cultures as well in tata steel
so surely you had something ready
yeah another successful day for the
Vienna very successful it could have
been I mean yeah it was anyone else
playing but me but you know no I mean I
guess this is just or also like yeah I
mean it's very unclear actually I think
I mean I'm not so sure if Queen takes D5
was that good actually
I think is just very strong
now if he goes Queen yeah
Bishop is distribution of xb7 is at the
end
I'm up with some bones
yeah but still
um kind of yeah decided so yeah and
queen D3 should have been played I hold
something
it was stupid actually
as per usual what was the hallucination
yeah I was sure Bishop D6 what am I
playing but I mean instead of um
and I didn't see but I mean I can just
you know
it seems like the only move right now is
to take on D5 yeah
no no Bishop takes D6 actually works
yeah take and here they're just animal
is winning But like after d takes C4 I
mean the bishop takes D6 DC4
yeah Queen I mean I guess Queen D2 and I
just didn't see if we need to Apples
Queen G3
is covered so like Knight H3 and
okay yeah yeah that's probably over the
king is stuck in the center yeah
um but even after Queen to D5 this game
was absolutely wild yeah I guess I could
have still played better Quincy check
instead of um
yeah here
C8 yeah I kind of in Knight h31
yeah this look like critical the
critical position and I I was I wasn't
really sure
um I mean I didn't see what he plays
obviously I felt like I'm kind of safe
but you know the problem was that foot
but I'm playing must be winning because
I'm able to bring in the night so I
figured with three attackers that should
do the trick but yeah and you were close
I mean yeah I made this judgment goal
and um let's lucky ourselves this was
really close
and uh we were analyzing it with Gary he
stayed for the whole run here in the
city and he was really enjoying this
game
um at this point I think he was
mentioning
Queen to C5 or perhaps yeah I think it's
later on because I have three he takes
every time
he takes previous three that's his only
trick right so I have to do it between
C7 which I did actually I just gained
some time into repeating yeah so like
here 93 right because he cannot take
them yes and then we can go again yes
the game looks like it could be winning
and I had like one minute so I just went
for it but yeah I could have taken the
opponent yeah
the idea I mean it's just absolutely
incredible you know that 95 King E7
holes yeah I mean and we were looking at
Queen before yeah yeah sure and looking
goes to F no it's just um yeah it's very
hard to I mean you know when you when
you're when you're little and you you
you look at these positions you're like
okay it's over again
right just by
not not too much no just by playing it
no no because you know I mean I have
given myself plenty of pleasure
yesterday as well by losing too easily
and I felt like I'm continuing uh giving
myself these pleasures of you know
throwing away half points here and there
so this was another example so you know
I didn't feel particularly happy with
this one or with the follow-up so you
know well actually that was another very
interesting game the game between uh
yourself and mvl and you had some
chances yeah we could say that
once again you started with the French
and you've played this in classical
chess against him as well uh you guys
have some sort of this ongoing battle
not really French so I just sometimes
play French and I guess 93 is kind of
principles yeah yeah
and did you feel like you were
getting the advantage at any point in
this game yeah I felt like I was
completely winning I guess the end as
also often it happens
but now you know I mean I kind of feel
like you're torturing movies because
okay you're asking me if I was
completely been minus five and I you
know
okay yeah yeah well it is rapid chess a
lot of these swings do happen
um yesterday was a difficult day
especially because of that last round
that you mentioned today you start the
ship a little bit slowly down what are
the plans for the final day
uh well for the Plus for fighting day I
don't know I don't I would hope not to
be actually winning maybe that that will
be this week just to make draws without
being winning
sounds like a
like a heavy person's plan yeah
otherwise it will be a very
very painful day one way or the other
for someone yeah Richie despite the fact
that uh you know today there were no
decisive results in your game still just
incredible enjoyment for everybody
watching these games so thank you and
we'll see you tomorrow thanks
a very self-deprecating uh Richie report